[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
يعالج احباط وعد بتكثيف الدعم واشاده
ببطوله زيلينسكي والاخير يرفض تجنيد
الصراع
واردوغان يخطبوا الجميع اجل التصديق على
انضمام السويد وقدم نفسه صديقا لروسيا
ووسيطا لانهاء الحرب
السودان بتحويله لحرب عرقيه ويشكك في
قبولهم ضمن مستقبل البلاد السياسي
ولدينا ايضا
الاتحاد التونسي للشغل يتهم الحكومه
بالفشل ويطالب برحيلها ويرفض تسكين الشارع
عبر تعديل وزاري
البدايه من ليتوانيا وخطاب الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن للرئيس الاوكراني
البيت الابيض اشاد بصمود نظيره الاوكراني
وصمود قواته قائلا له مباشره انه يتفهم
شعوره بالاحباط احيانا مما يتلقاه لكنه
وعده ببذل كل جهود لمساعدته في حربه
تدربجي
اعلموا انه في كثير من الاحيان تشعر
بالاحباط بشان ما اذا كانت الاشياء تصل
اليك بسرعه كافيه وما الذي يصل اليك وكيف
نصل الى هناك لكنني اعدك ان تبذل الولايات
المتحده كلما في وسعها لتوفر لك ما تحتاجه
في اسرع وقت ممكن لقد انجزت عملا هائلا
لديك الكثير لفعله اعلم بل انا متاكد من
حصولك على ما تحتاجه اتطلع الى اليوم الذي
نعقد فيه اجتماعا احتفالا بعضويتك الرسميه
في الناتو
كانت مجموعه سبع اعلنت عن اطار عمل دولي
ومهد الطريق لضمانات امنيه على المدى
الطويل لاوكرانيا تشمل توفير المعدات
العسكريه المتطوره والتدريب وتبادل
معلومات المخابرات والدفاع الالكترونيه
وفي المقابل ستجرك يا اصلاحات قضائيه
واقتصاديه وتعزز الشفافيه
الرئيس الاوكراني رحب بالضمانات الامنيه
من مجموعه السبع وان جدد الاشاره لهدف
بلاده الاهم وهو الانضمام الى النيتو
رافضا في الوقت ذاته تجميد الصراع مع
روسيا
هناك ضمانات يمكن تاكيدها من قبل مجموعه
الدول السبع هذا سوف يحدث من شان هذا
الامر ان يصبح خطوه مهمه ونجاحا محددا
ويمكننا ان نشير الى ان مخرجات هذه القمه
كانت جيده لكن اذا ما تلقينا دعوه
للانضمام الى النيتو فهذا سيكون الهدف
الاعظم
ان رئيس الفرنسي
للالتزام بحزمه امنيه طويله الاجل
لاوكرانيا طالما استمر الهجوم الروسي
بالاضافه الى الجهد التي بذلناها على
المدى القصير نحتاج الى مواصله تقديم
الدعم على المدى الطويل طالما كان ذلك
ضروريا وطالما استمر هذا الهجوم على
اوكرانيا هذا هو بالضبط معنى الالتزامات
الامنيه التي تعهد بها شركاء مجموعه السبع
الاوكرانيه يمكن لجميع الحلفاء بالطبع
الانضمام وقد اكد البعض رغبتهم في
الانضمام الى هذا الالتزام الذي يمثل جهدا
جماعيا طويل الاجل تجاه اوكرانيا وجيشها
وشعبها
الرئيس التركي الذي كانت كلمته محل اهتمام
من الحلفاء في النيتو ومن الروس على حد
سواء شدد على ان بلاده لم تسمح لاي سفن
حربيه بعبور مضائقها منذ اليوم الاول
للحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه كما اشار الى ان
روسيا غيرت موقفها من تسليم انقره لقاده
كتيبه ازول بعد اطلاعهم على بعض الظروف
مشيرا الى انه سيناقش هذا الملف مع الرئيس
بوتين مباشره اردوغان اكد كذلك ان بلاده
تلعب دور الوسيط لانهاء الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا اما فيما يتعلق بعضويه الموافقه
عضويه السويد في النيتو فاكد اردوغان ان
تركيا لن تصادق على الامر قبل اكتوبر
المقبل
تركيا قد تلعب دور الوسيط بين روسيا
واوكرانيا للتوصل الى اتفاق لانهاء الحرب
اذا وافق البلدين على ذلك وفيما يتعلق
بعضويه السويد في الناتو سنحيل الطلب الى
البرلمان التركي للمصادقه عليه عندما يعود
للانعقاد ولكن لن نصادق على عضويه السويد
في النيتو قبل اكتوبر المقبل السويد ستتخذ
خطوات ملموسه ضد الارهاب بموجب الاتفاق
بين البلدين
رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان يزداد قربا من
الغرب مبتعدا اكثر فاكثر عن موسكو وفق
تقرير
الصحيفه قالت ان اردوغان كان مدفوعا
بالازمه الاقتصاديه في بلاده تحول للغرب
الان وهو ما قد تكون له تداعيات بعيده
المدى على ميزان القوه في اوروبا والحرب
في اوكرانيا لاكثر من عام رفض الرئيس
التركي انضمام السويد للضغط على الغرب
والحصول على تنازلات على صعود عده السويد
على سبيل المثال اصبحت قوانين مكافحه
الارهاب والغت القيود المفروضه على مبيعات
الاسلحه الى تركيا كما ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي بات اكثر انفتاحا على فتح ملف
انضمام تركيا للتكاثر الاوروبي محللون
اوكرانيا للنيتو واستقبل الرئيس الاوكراني
في تركيا وسلمه قاده كتيبه ازوف واسقط
الاعتراض على دخول السويد للحلف خلال
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه فقط التحولات التركيه
ستخفف نسبيا من العلاقه المتواتره مع
واشنطن والقوه الاوروبيه ومن المحتمل ان
تفسح او تفسح هذه التطورات المجال لتتسلم
تركيا مقات 16 بعشرين مليار دولار من
الولايات المتحده حتى الان سارى رئيس
تركيا على خط ضيق بين معارضه التدخل
الروسي في اوكرانيا والحفاظ على العلاقات
الوثيقه مع نظيره
الحرب في اوكرانيا وسع التركان مع روسيا
واستعانت بموسكو كمصدر العمله الاجنبيه
كما اظهرت بيانات تجاريه ان روسيا اشترت
عشرات الملايين من الدولارات من المواد
التي تحتاجها لقواتها المسلحه من تركيا
منذ بدايه الحرب على جانب الاخر بات
الرئيس الروسي يواجه التحالفا الذي يضم
اثنتين دوله بدلا من 30 قبل الحرب مع
ابتعاد الحلفاء عنه ولو بشكل طفيف مجله
اشارت الى نابوتين لا يخسر الحلفاء على
المستوى الدولي فحسب بل يخسر على المستوى
المحلي ايضا كما ظهر من تمرد فاجنر قصير
الامد الشهر الماضي معنى من اسطنبول الان
الكاتب والمحلل سياسي مهند حافظ
السياسي اهلا بك كذلك دعنا استاذ
نفهم الدكتور مهند طبيعه هذه التحولات
التركيه ما الذي يفرضها الان دكتور
جميع المشاهدين الضيف الكريم بالفعل هناك
تغيرات على الاقل على مستوى التصريحات
يعني لا نستطيع ان نقول بان تركيا
وسياساتها قد غيرت الكفى وتوجهها واتجهت
مره اخرى الى الغرب بالرغم من انها بطبيعه
الحال بطريقه اخرى هي في المنظومه الغربيه
ولكن انها ضربت بالشرق وبيروسيا عرض
الحائط وتوجهت بالكامل الى الغرب هذا يبدو
لي الامر
بحاجه الى المزيد من الوقت لنتاكد منه
لماذا روسيا ايضا قالت انه تركيا بهذه
السياسات تتحول الى دوله غير صديقه
صحيح صحيح هناك خلافات كبيره وروسيا
مبتعضه جدا من تصريحات الرئيس اردوغان ومن
تصرفاتي من خلال تسليم قاده
ازوفكي ولكن هذا
الامتعاض هل سوف يتحول الى توتر والى
القطع للعلاقات او لتخفيض مستوى التنسيق
ما بين الطرفين ام لا هذا له ثلاثه
اعتبارات او ثلاثه مؤشرات نستطيع من
خلالها ان نفهم ماذا سوف يكون اختصار لو
سمحتي اولا
هل سوف يكون هناك زياره للرئيس بوتين الى
تركيا هل سوف يمدد ازمه الحبوب اتفاقيه
الحبوب مده اضافيه بضغط تركي وهل سوف يكون
هناك تصعيد روسي في الشمال السوري لانه
كنا نعلم يدرك اننا مؤخرا منذ سنتين وثلاث
سنوات ربما كلما كان هناك خلافا ما بين
تركيا وروسيا نرى بريد الصندوق البريد
يكون في صوره من خلال تصعيد في يعني انت
تراهن على الالتزام الروسي به ذه بهذه
المواضيع الثلاثه رغم كل ما اغضب به
اردوغان موسكو في الايام الاخيره صحيح
صحيح هذه مؤشرات اساسيه ومهمه بغض النظر
عن التصريحات الحاده
العاليه النبره من قبل موسكو الا ان هناك
المؤشرات العمليه هذه هي التي سوف تحكم
هذه العلاقه لا ننسى الظهر بان موسكو
بحاجه ماسه لانقر في هذه المرحله ولا تريد
ان تخسرها خساره كبيره بسبب
ستعرض اسلحه الناتو المدمره امام سفارات
الدول التي تزود كييف بها هدف في الخبر
العاجل على الهواء ولكن في نقاشنا نتابع
معك لناخذ وجهه نظرك ما هي الاعتبارات
التي ستبني عليها موسكو قراراتها في
المواضيع اللي ذكرها الدكتور مهند وهي
الاهم الان توجيه دعوه زياره الى بوتين هل
سيزور تركيا او لا موضوع اتفاقيه الحبوب
تمديد من عدمه والتصعيد الروسي في الشمال
السوري
نعم مساء الخير تحياتي لكم
الكريم اعتقد بكل تاكيد هناك
تغييرات كبيره حدثت في العلاقات الروسيه
التركيه عندما تم اسقاط الطائره الروسيه
على الاراضي السوريه في السابق وكان هناك
توتر
وتصعيد بين الطرفين بين روسيا وتركيا على
الاراضي السوريه نحن الان بكل تاكيد
التوجه التركي بعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التي شهدتها تركيا وفوز رئيس تركيا ايضا
هي تحولات سياسيه تحدث في الداخل التركي
وهي ايضا تؤثر على السياسه الخارجيه
التركي من ناحيه ان اردوغان يجب ان يتعامل
مع جزء من الشعب التركي الذي لم لم يعني
ينتخبه او هو الذي يعارضه ولذلك هو يحاول
حل هذه المشاكل في المدن الكبرى حيث هو
يتحدث اكثر شيء عن التقارب مع دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي والدول الغربيه وهذه شيء ايضا
نقطه مهمه لان تركيا هي لعبه مهمه في حلف
الشمال الاطلسي روسيا من موقف تركيا ترى
بان هذا الموقف طبعا تراه عدائي هو موقف
يعني يحاول تحاول فيه تركيا الابتعاد نوعا
ما عن روسيا ولكن هناك تفاهمات كبيره
تفاهمات اقتصاديه من شانها حل هذه المشاكل
لان لا اعتقد بان التركيه جاهزه لخساره
السياحه الروس والشركات الروسيه
والمستثمرين الروس وايضا الروس ليست جاهزه
لخساره تركيا كشريك مهم استراتيجي اقتصادي
وتجاري فهذه التفاهمات الاقتصاديه
والتجاريه هي اكبر من ازمه يمكن ان تحدث
بين الدولتين واعتقد بان في
ربما يستطيع ان يحقق اداره ما للنزاع ولكن
ليس ان تكون العلاقه كما كانت بدون شك
لانه موسكو كانت تريد ان تلعب دور الوسيط
الان يعني انقره كانت تريد ان تلعب دور
الوسيط هل موسكو ستقبل بذلك من الان
فصاعدا
اعتقد بان بكل تاكيد اعتقد بان كما قلت
تفاهمات بين الرئيسين الرئيس التركي رجب
تايبردوغان والرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
هي اكبر من اي خلافات قد تحدث نعم يجب ان
نفهم بان كما قلت تركيا هي لعبه مهمه في
حلف الشمال الاطلسي تركيا تريد حل المشاكل
الاقتصاديه الان والتي بكل تاكيد تؤثر على
المواطن التركي فخطوات رجب طيب اردوغانيه
محاوله لي ان يكون وايضا بسيط بين الغرب
والشرق هذه الخطوه هي ايضا خطوه مهمه لان
يجب ان نفهم بان تركيا دائما كانت تحاول
التوازن في علاقتها بين الصف الغربي
وروسيا نعم بكل تاكيد هذا التوجه استفز
روسيا روسيا رات بان هذا التوجه هو نوعا
ما ابتعاد عن الموقف الذي كانت تريده
روسيا منذ البدايه من تركيا وهو التقارب
مع روسيا وبناء تحالف روسي تركي وحتى في
الشؤون الاقتصاديه والتجاريه كون روسيا
مهتمه بان ترى تركيا شريكه استراتيجيا
مهما ولكن الان كما قلت
يحاول حل المشاكل الداخليه لان بعض
الانتخابات هناك بعض المشاكل تواجه
التركيه هناك بعدها انت ايضا انتخابات في
تركيا وحزب العداله والتنميه يريد حل هذه
المشاكل في الداخل التركي في المدن الكبرى
الى هذه الفتره والى الاتحاد الاوروبي منه
الى المعسكر الشرقي اذا صح التعبير وهذا
ما نتحدث عنه بعد قليل خاصه اذا ما اجبنا
على السؤال الاتي ما الذي سيغيرهم انضمام
السويد وفنلندا من خريطه المواجهه بين
روسيا والحلف التقرير التي يحمل اجابه ما
نعود للنقاش
كلما ارتفع علم جديد في مقر الناتو تحلق
في سماء اوروبا والعالم اسئله حول مدى
التغيير الذي سيحدثه ذلك حلف شمال الاطلسي
في السويد وفنلندا مختلف تماما عن ذي قبل
واربع خرائط توضح ذلك
كبار الحلف واثقون من ان التاريخ لا يكفي
والمزيد من الجغرافيا سيمنحهم قوه اكثر
فنلندا الدوله المحايده تقليديا انضمامها
الى جانب السويد يشكل خطوه ستغير المشهد
الامني في اوروبا خلال السنوات المقبله
وسيزيد من توتر العلاقات مع روسيا
عضويه السويد وفنلندا تمنح الحلف ميزه في
بحر البلطيق وهو ممر مائي استراتيجي تحده
مدينه
الروسيه بالاضافه الى بعض اعضاء الناتو
الاكثر ضعفا
انضمام السويد الى الناتو يعني وجودا
متزايدا في القطب الشمالي فالبلدان عضوان
في مجلس القطب الشمالي واكثر من 50% من
ساحل المحيط المتجمد الشمالي عباره عن
اراد روسيه
حدود فنلندا مع روسيا تمتد لاكثر من 800
ميل وانضمام هذا البلد سيضاعف الحدود
البريه للتحالف ما يوفر للناتو قوه ردع
معززه وموسكو ستحتاج لجهود اكبر للدفاع عن
هذه الحدود انضمام فنلندا والسويد الى حلف
الناتو يمنحهما غطاء ودعما في حال تعرضهما
لاي هجوم لكن المخاطر مرتفعه ايضا فقد
يتحولان الى العشب الذي يداس في حال
اندلاع معركه بين السيران الكبار بلال
البجدين العربيه
نعود الى ضيفينا وتركيا كانت عاملا مساهما
اساسيا بل حاسما في
البدء بضم السويد بعد فنلندا دكتور مهند
حافظ اوغلو الى اي مدى يمكن لتركيا
اردوغان او اي رئيس اخر ان تحافظ على اي
موقع وسطي كان الرئيس اردوغان يقول انه
يريد ان يموضع تركيا فيه في العلاقه بين
روسيا والنيتو اذا ما يعني تفاقمت الامور
واذا ما دخل النت فعليا ليس فقط في
المساعده انما في الحرب بنفسها
مؤثر العميلان هو انه موقع تركيا الجيوس
يفرض عليها هذه النوع من السياسات
والبعد الاخر هو ان كل من الشرق والغرب
يدركان تماما اهميه هذا الدور التركي وهذه
السياسه التي تنتهجها ولا ينزعجون من انها
لا تذهب لا الى شرق بالكامل ولا الى الغرب
بالكامل ولكن
البعد الاهم في كل ما يجري هو ان كل ما
جرى في قمه حلف الشمال الاطلسي يبدو لي
وكانها تترخص يا ايها الناس اطربتنا
فاطربناك وهناك ثلاثه اشهر فتره اختبار
حقيقيه لاي تصرفات ولاي تحركات سويديه
اوروبيه تجاه تركيا والا لن يكون هناك اي
تطور عملي حقيقي ولا تستعجل العواصم
الغربيه هذه الفرحه بانضمام السويد الى
حلف شمال الاطلسين المشوار دونه مع وقات
كبيره دون وجود كبير الكره اليوم في
الملعب السويدي والملعب الملعب الاوروبي
والملعب الامريكي لكي يضغطون على
السياسات التي ينتهجونها في دعم الارهاب
ومن قاموا بمحاوله انقلاب في تركيا هذا
كله سوف يخضع لي الاختبار والفتره هذه سوف
تؤكد هل هذا الحمل كان حملا كاذبا ام ان
هناك نوايا صادقه وجاده وبالتالي المضي
قدما نحو تحالف اكثر قوه وليكون اعضاءه 32
دوله وبالتالي تضييق الخناق السياسي
الاعلامي على روسيا ولا اظن ان الحلف
الناتو يريد ان يدخل في حرب مباشره مع
روسيا وان كانت روسيا تقول اليوم اننا على
وشك بدا حرب عالميه ثالثه ولكن هذا لن
يكون
ذلك البدء مباشره في هكذا امور استاذ
ديمتري الى اي مدى سببت روسيا لنفسها
توسيع بعد الحرب في اوكرانيا توسيع جبهه
النيتو الى اي مدى اسهمت من حيث تدري او
لا تدري وتريد او لا تريد بتوسيع جبهات
النيتو على حدودها مباشره
بكل تاكيد المعركه مع اوكرانيا اثرت كثيرا
على توسيع الناتو وحتى نرى بان الان هناك
يمكن القول بناء او محاوله لبناء حلف
اوكرانيا الحلف الشمالي الاطلسي اوكرانيا
الناتو وهذا الشيء ايضا يزيد من خطوره
المعركه وخطوره والتصعيد الذي نشهده بين
الطرفين نسيم بان هناك مزيد من الاسلحه
سوف يتم تقديمها للطرف الاوكراني في
الاشهر القادمه من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك معلومات
استخباراتيه ايضا يتم تقديمها فالمعركه
اصبحت يمكن ان تاخذ يعني او تكون واسعه
النطاق وهذا الشيء قد نرى فيه تهديدا
مباشرا وايضا تصعيدا خطيرا لان بكل تاكيد
التصريحات الان والتهابات متبادله كان من
الطرف الروسي من
السياسيين الروس ومن طرف دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذين يرون ايضا في توسيع روسيا
وفي محاولات روسيا
للضغط على دول تمام الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا
تهديدا للحلف الشماليه ود فيبدو بان بكل
تاكيد هذه الاشهر القادمه سوف تكون حاسمه
واين ايضا يجب ان نفهم بان الرئيس
الاوكراني يحاول ايضا التصعيد ضروسي من
حيث هو يريد ان يحصل على مزيد من الدعم
والاسلحه وهذا يستفز روسيا هذه الخطوات هي
فقط تصعيديه وهي خطوات قد تسبب حرب كبيره
دعني اخصص يعني الدقيقه المتبقيه الى ما
يقوله بوري عن الشعور بالقلق العميق اذا
عدم تجديد قرار اممي بسبب ذات روسي بخصوص
ايصال المساعدات لشمال الغرب سوريا وهذا
كان جزء من نقاشنا قبل قليل للتو مع
الدكتور مهند وحضرتك اشرت الى انه هذا بند
اساسي من البنود التي يجب ان نبقي عينا
عليها زياره بوتين تمديد اتفاقيه الحبوب
اي تصعيد روسي محتمل في الشمال الروسي هل
بدات روسيا باعتقادك بالرد من الشمال
السوري
مضطره روسيا
الرد الخنا
قض والضغط الاعلامي السياسي الروسي
الاستخباراتي الامني كبير جدا ولا ننسى
المقصود الرد على تركيا تحديدا هدف من كل
على ادلب على شمال سوريا
روسيا سوف ترد ليس فقط على تركيا بل على
حتى على دول حلف الشمال الاطلسي مبتدئه
بسوريا لان ايضا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه معنيه بشكل اساسي بالملف السوري
وهناك القوات الفرنسيه والوجود الفرنسي لا
ننسى وهناك ايضا توترا روسيا ايرانيا منذ
اقل من 24 ساعه اذا الروسيا اليوم بالفعل
يزداد الخناق عليها والضغط عليها لذلك هي
سوف ترد ولا يمكن لاحد ان يركد او يخمن
اين سوف ترد روسيا نقطه اخيره استاذ طاهر
لو سمحت لي الهدف في قراءه المتواضعه من
كل ما يجري في الحرب الاوكرانيه هناك
هدفان اساسيان كبيران ضخمان بعيدان المدى
الهدف الاساسي الاول هو استبقاء او محاوله
ابقاء الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انها
تبقى القطب الاوحد سياسيا عسكريا
للعالم اولا وثانيا اضعاف الاتحاد
الاوروبي وعدم انشاء اي جيش موازي لانها
كما كانت تريد المانيا وفرنسا تمام
ناخذ رايي باختصار شديد استاذ هل بدات
روسيا من خلال الامم المتحده بموضوع ادخال
مساعدات الى شمال سوريا بالرد على تركيا
والغرب
اعتقد بكل تاكيد الان الملف السوري هو
مرتبط بالملف الاوكراني والملفات الاخرى
التي
او لروسيا يدفيها بكل تاكيد سوريا هي ارض
او مكان فيه كثير من النفود النفوس
الامريكي النفود التركي فبكل تاكيد الرد
سوف يكون في سوريا وبكل تاكيد سوف نرى
تصعيدا يمكن يحدث في الاراضي السوريه في
الاشهر القادمه كانت روسي على الضغط وعلى
خناق الذي تفرضه الدول الغربيه على روسيا
لان روسيا لها قواعد عسكريه في الصوره لها
نفوت وهي تريد الاحتفاظ بهذا النفود ولذلك
هذا الان التنافس بين الغرب روسيا قد يؤثر
ايضا على الملف السوري وعلى التنافس الذي
يحدث في سوريا
وتستنقل عن وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان
مخرجات قمه النيتو فينيس تبدي بشكل نهائي
العوده الى مسار الحرب البارده شكرا جزيلا
لكم الدكتور مهند حافظ اوغلو المحلل سياسي
من اسطنبول شكرا للاستاذنتري براجيا
المحلل السياسي من موسكو تحياتي اليكما
ويبدو ان التوتر بين روسيا ودول نيتو قد
انعكس ميدانيا اذ نقلت وكاله الانباء
الروسيه عن وزاره الدفاع عن روسيا ارسلت
طائره مقاتله من طراز 31 لمنع طائره
نرويجيه من اختراق حدودها فوق بحر بارنت
هذا واعلن الجيش الروسي انه تسلم من
مجموعه اكثر من 2000 قطعه من المعدات
العسكريه تشمل دبابات عقيبه تمردها وقالت
الدفاع الروسيه انها تلقت ايضا حول 2500
طن من الذخيره وحاول عشرين الف قطعه سلاح
خفيف
في الرابع والعشرين من يونيو قادر قافله
عسكريه متجها من ريستوف جنوبا باتجاه
موسكو بهدف الاطاحه بوزير الدفاع وقائد
الاركان قتل في ذلك اليوم 15 عسكريا وبدت
روسيا على شفا حرب اهليه وخرج بوتين غاضبا
يصف بروجين بالخائن
وهكذا فان الافعال التي قسمت وحدتنا هي في
انقلاب على شعبنا من رفاقنا في السلاح
الذين يقاتلون على خط المواجهه الان انما
يحدث هو طعنه في ظهر بلدنا وشعبنا
في حاله قيام الولايات المتحده بتزويد
اوكرانيا بالقنابل العنقوديه ستضطر القوات
الروسيه الى استخدام اسلحه مماثله كاجراء
ضد الجيش الاوكراني روسيا لديها قنابل
عنقوديه لجميع المناسبات فهي اكثر فعاليه
من الامريكيه ومتنوعه على نطاق واسع
وسط الحديث الروسي عن اقتراب حرب عالميه
ثالثه يبدو ان بوتين ينجح في اعاده ترتيب
بيته الداخلي قاده جيشه يعودون بثقه وجنود
فاغنر المرتزقه يتعهدون بالقتال والولائل
الكرمله
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا الامم المتحده تقول
ان عدد من تركوا منازلهم في السودان جبل
الحرب تجاوز ثلاثه ملايين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد حضر رئيس البعثه
الاماميه في السودان
طرف اي صراع باستمرار تجنيد المقاتلين على
هذا الاساس
الطرفان لا يستطيع ان تحقيق انتصار عسكري
ويمتلكان قوه بشريه لذلك كانت جانبا
يجندان من خارج تشكيلاتهم الخاصه على اساس
عرقي او قبل او حتى ايدولوجي نحن هنا على
شفاء هذه الحرب بين تشكيلتين عسكريتين
تتحولان الى حرب اهليه عرقيه وقبليه
في احتمال ان يقبل السودانيون بان يكون
للاطراف المتحاربه اي وجود في المناصب
القياديه في مرحله ما بعد الحرب
المسائله مفهوم اوسع بكثير من مجرد مفهوم
قضائي انها على الاقل بالنسبه لعمله هي
ايضا مفهوم سياسي انها تتعلق بما اذا كان
الشعب السوداني سيسمح لقاده الاطراف
المتحاربه بايه وظيفه قياديه بعد هذه
الحرب ربما لوضعها في جمله واحده ما زلنا
بحاجه لان تنهي قاده الاطراف المتحاربه
تلك الحرب لكنني لا اعتقد انه يمكن ان
يكون لهم دور في بناء السلام
في الاثناء اكد وزير الخارجيه السوداني
علي الصادق ان الحكومه تنظر بايجابيه
لمبادره الوساطه المصريه لكنه حذر من
صعوبه تحقيق هدفها اذا شارك فيها اخرون من
خارج المنطقه واتهم وزير الخارجيه
السودانيه الرئيس الكيني ورئيس الوزراء
الاثيوبي باحمد بالسعي لتحقيق مكاسبه في
الاقليم قائلا ان هذا لن يكون على حساب
السودان
وقد فرضت لندن عقوبات جديده على عدد من
الشركات المرتبطه بقاده الجيش وقوه الدعم
السريع في السودان واوضحت ان العقوبات من
شانها ان تمنع مواطني وشركات وبنوك
بريطانيا من التعامل مع هذه الشركات
والضغط على الاطراف السودانيه للانقراض في
عمليه السلام
اعلنت الامم المتحده ان اكثر من ثلاثه
ملايين شخص طروا الى مغادره ديارهم بسبب
النزاع في السودان وبحسب المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره فان عدد الاشخاص الذين فروا من
القتال في السودان في الخارج يقترب من 724
الفا بينما يتجاوز عدد النازحين داخل
البلاد مليونين و400 الف شخص وافادت منظمه
بان العدد تجاوز ثلاثه ملايين مما اضطروا
الى مغادره ديارهم بسبب النزاع في السودان
مضيفه الى ان هناك حاجه ما السائل وقف
فوري للقتال في هذا البلد والحصول على دعم
دائم من المجتمع الدولي لتقديم المساعده
والحمايه للمتضررين من النزاع
ميدانيه شهد محيط مطار الخرطوم انفجارات
قويه وتصاعدا لاعمده الدخان مع تجدد غارات
الجيش ورد الدعم السريع بمضادات الطيران
[موسيقى]
الان الى الخرطوم مع صحفي عمار ابو شيبه
اهلا بك معنا عمار اخر التطورات على الارض
ما الذي يحصل الان كيف تعيش الخرطوم
ليلتها هذه
نعم هذه الليله دعنا نبدا فيها من اخر
تحديث طاهر كنا نستمع قبل لحظات الى تحليق
كثيف لطائرات الاستطلاع التابعه للجيش
السوداني في العاده دائما ما تحلق نهارا
بشكل كثيف على غير المعتاد ان تحلق ليلا
في كثير من ارجاع العاصمه الخرطوم قبل ذلك
بلحظات طاهر هنا في شرق وجنوب العاصمه
الخرطوم كنا نستمع الى انفجارات
استمرت لعدد من الدقائق في منطقه بري
ومنطقه الجاردن سيتي ومنطقه احياء الصفا
كنا نستمع الى هذه الاصوات من هذا الاتجاه
الشرقي العاصمه الخرطوم ايضا مع هذا
الرصاص الطائش بين فتره واخرى في شرق
وجنوب العاصمه الخرطوم الذي لا يتوقف سواء
في فتره النهار او فتره الليل مع عدد من
المعارك التي كانت تدور صباحا خاصه وان
عمليات القصف الجوي استمرت لعدد من
الساعات بشكل كثيف استخدم فيها الجيش
المسيرات والطائرات المقاتله وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم وجنوب العاصمه الخرطوم وشرق وجنوب
العاصمه ايضا الناس مع الاعلان عن رقم
يقترب من ثلاثه ملايين اغلبهم في الداخل
ولكن يبقى رقم كبيرا يعني كيف يكيفون
انفسهم مع استمرار امد هذه الحرب الطويله
دون وجود اي امال بانهائها حاليا
نعم دعنا اقص ان نقص عددنا القصص فيما يخص
عمليات التكيف مع واقع الحرب المريض في
عدد من الاحياء مثلا احياء شمبات بمدينه
بحري التي تنقطع عنها المياه منذ الايام
الاولى من اندلاع الحرب يعيشون بشكل صعب
جدا يذهبون الى
النيل ويجلبون المياه من تلك المنطقه في
عمليه صعبه جدا محفوفه
بالمخاطر ايضا تنقطع الكهرباء عن هذه
الاحياء منذ ذلك الوقت يعيشون بلا كهرباء
تنقطع الاتصالات في تلك المناطق بشكل كبير
يصعب التواصل مع كثيرين سواء تعرضوا
للاصابات او حتى تعرضوا لعمليه اقتحام
للمنازل او حتى لعمليات قصف جوي او رصاص
طائش لا يستطيعون الاتصال حتى باسعاف يعني
طيله هذه الفتره طاهر لك ان تتخيل اننا لم
نستمع الى صوت سياره اسعاف في ارجاء
العاصمه الخرطوم او تصل الى عدد من
المصابين او الجرحى حدث اخرى عن ان هنالك
موتى نعم هنالك موتى في المستشفيات مات
وهم ينزفون دما لعدم توفر كثير من
المطببات وعدم توفرها الكادر الطبي في
المشافي التي اصبحت خاليه ومغلقه بفعل
الاشتباكات التي تدور منذ قرابه التسعين
يوما شكرا جزيلا لك الصحفي عمر ابو شيبه
من الخرطوم تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
قام رئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس بزياره الى
مدينه جنين ومخيمها هي الاولى منذ اكثر من
10 سنوات واكد عباس خلال الزياره التي
استمرت نحو ساعتين ان شعب الفلسطيني لن
يرحل عن ارضه وان عمليه اعمار مخيم جنين
متواصله حتى يعود افضل من مكان
قال المتحدث الرسمي وبسم الاتحاد التونسي
للشغل سامي الطاهري ان تونسيين ينتظرون
رحيل حكومه نجلاء بودن متهم اياها بالفشل
على جميع المستويات كما شدد على رفض
الاتحاد اي حلول مؤقته تكتفي بتغيير بعض
الوزراء
كل
اظني يفكر فيه بعمق هو لهذه الحكومه كلها
تذهب وترحل لان كانت فاشله لها انها منذ
كونك سبتمبر
الى الان لم تحل مشكله في كل القضايا هات
نشوف ملف الملف وانفسجد هذه الحكومه عاجزه
على قيمتها
الهجره لم تستطع رغم انه جديد مش مستحدث
لم تستطع مجابهته الى ان استدخل الى هذه
الحاله ملف المديونيه ملف التفاوض مع
صندوق النقد الدولي اللي صفر نتائج ملف
الخروج من الازمه الاقتصاديه والركود
وغياب الاستثمار
انهيار الدينار الى غير ذلك يعني اهلنا مع
حكومه ما تتطلقش ترقيع واحنا نعرفو اللي
تم على الاقل تمشي الوزراء كما الوزراء لا
يشتغل اصحابها يعني
باسمهم يمشي كل يوم ويروح وما عندهاش لما
مشروع لا حول ولا المشاكل
والحكومه غائبه بالاتصال بما فيها رئيستها
انا اعتقد انه مثلا
يمكن امتصاص على الفشل الحاصل بمجرد ترقيع
من هذا الوزير
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا
في مهرجانات بامبلور على الاسبانيه الكل
سعداء بالمشاركه الا طرف واحد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في الوقت الذي يتواصل
فيه اضراب الكتاب الامريكيين نحو شهرين
يبدو ان اضربا اخر في الطريق مما يمثلون
الشاشه الامريكيه وفنانيه التليفزيون
والريديو وذلك بسبب نقص الاجور وفق قولهم
ونقص الضمانات بما يخص استخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي في صناعه الفنون
خلف هذه المشاهد البراقه معارك يسمونها
بالوجوديه والسبب العوائد والذكاء
الاصطناعي
نقابه ممثلي الشاشه الاتحاد الامريكي
للفنانين راديو والتلفزيون التي تمثل 160
الف ممثل تهدد بالاضراب لتنضم الى نحو
11,500 عضو في نقابه الكتاب الامريكيه
اضربوا عن العمل في اوائل مايو واقع يرعب
صناع السينما الذين يسابقون الزمن للوصول
الى حل قبل مهله منتصف الليل خاصه بعد ان
تضامنت اسماء رنانه كاميرل ستريب وجنيفر
لورنس مع مطالب الممثلين النقابه تطالب
بالحمايه الماليه لاعضائها عبر تعويضات
تتعلق بالبث التلفزيوني عبر الانترنت حيث
يتلقى الممثلون مبلغا ثابتا عن اعاده عرض
اعمالهم بغض النظر عن عدد المشاهدات كما
يطالبون بضمانات ترتبط بالذكاء الاصطناعي
والا فالاضراب المفتوح
الاضراب ان استمر سيمثل ضربه كبيره
للصناعه الترفيه خاصه للافلام ذات
الميزانيات الكبيره وسيكون اول احتجاج
مزدوج للممثلين وكتاب السيناريو فيه
هوليود منذ عام 1960
ثوره الذكاء الاصطناعيه وصلت بالفعل الى
الرعايه الطبيه فيما يعد احد الاوجه
الايجابيه ربما لهذه التقنيه واشنطن بوست
نشرت تقريرا عن عياده مايو كلينك
الامريكيه والتي انشات اكثر من 160
خوارزميه ذكاء اصطناعي لتشخيص وعلاج امراض
القلب والاعصاب وعدد اخر من الامراض نتحدث
هنا عما يسمى بالذكاء الاصطناعي التنبئي
الذي يعتبر محاكاه او يعتبر محاكاه لذكاء
البشري عبر الالات بالنظر في تجارب ملايين
المرضى وامراضهم للمساعده في علاجها على
سبيل المثال فان كان شخص مصاب بمرض سكري
اذا كان شخص ما مصابا بمرض السكري من
النوع الثاني يمكن للخوارزميه التنبؤ
بافضل خطه رعايه باستخدامات عن العمر
الجغرافيه الخلفيه العرقيه العادات
الغذائيه تاريخ طبي للمريض الى ما هنالك
ربما هذا النوع من العلاج الذي يركز على
المريض ليس جديدا لكن الذكاء الاصطناعي
اداه اخرى للمساعده في اتخاذ القرارات
الطبيه المناسبه ايضا يمكن للذكاء
الاصطناعي تحسين الاكتشاف بشكل كبير وضع
بيانات لتحديد الاورام الحميده والخبيثه
لتقوم الخوارزميات بدورها باكتشاف نوع
الورم وتقليل هامش الخطا في اكتشاف الافات
السرطانيه لاكثر من النصف مسؤول قسم
الذكاء الاصطناعي في عياده مايو كلينك
نوعها الى انه في غضون السنوات الخمس
المقبله ربما يمكن اعتبار عدم استخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي في فحص سرطان القولون
والمستقيم من الممارسات الخاطئه الا انه
لن يحل محل الطبيب وعلى الرغم من ان
المسؤول من المؤيدين بوضوح لاستخدام ذكاء
الاصطناعي في الطب الا انه يحث على
الاشراف على التقنيه تماما كما تقوم اداره
الغذاء والدواء بفحص الادويه الجديده كما
اعتبر انه لابد من دراسه الذكاء الاصطناعي
مع تحذير من لا يحمل وعدا مطلقا
من انه لا يحمل وعدا مطلقا بجعل الرعايه
الصحيه اكثر امانا لكونه قابلا للصواب
والخطا معنى للمزيد من التفاصيل من عمان
دكتور محمد حجيري استشاري امراض
قلب
وكهرباء القلب كذلك اهلا بك معنا دكتور
اين وصل الذكاء الاصطناعي في الطب الان
وما هو متوقع في السنوات الخمس المقبله
هلا انا كطبيب قلب احنا اوريدي بنستعمل
الذكاء الاصطناعي في يعني بس مش بالحالات
اللي اللي وصلت فيها بالوقت الحالي مثلا
تخطيطات القلب في الوقت الحالي ممكن تحكي
لك اذا في المريض عنده مرض معين موجود على
تخطيط القلب هلا طبعا هذا الموضوع تقدم
بطريقه كبيره
لدرجه انه
الهولترز او المونيترز اللي هم
اللي بنعمله عشان يدوروا على امراض كهرباء
القلب في جزء منهم بنقرا تماما من الذكاء
الاصطناعي بحكي لك انه هذا المريض عنده
كذا وعنده كذا وعنده كذا هل هذا راح بس
باللي بتستعملوه حاليا نحن عم نحل الطبيب
قبل ما نحكي عن المستقبل اللي عم تستعمله
حاليا هو ذكاء اصطناعي 100%
باخطاء معينه بها مش خطا او او مئه بالمئه
نجاح او ماذا صحيح بها مش خطا لا لا ابدا
يعني طبعا فيها مش خطا فدائما بنرجع
للطبيب عشان نت اكد من اذا هذا الكلام
صحيح يعني ما بتعتمدوا عليه لحاله القلب
لازم يصير بالطريقه التقليديه بس للتجارب
تعتمدوا عليه اذا صحيح تجربه فقط
صحيح في الوقت الحالي في الوقت الحالي بس
هلا لما احنا نقارن يعني
دقه في القراءه خصوصي بالهولترز الجداد
عاليه يعني لما نقارن اذا يعني نسبه الخطا
5% عشره بالميه
يعني صعب بعتمد على حسب السوفت وير اللي
يستعمل
يعتمد على
الهاردوير الشغلات يعني في اكثر من عامل
لحتى نحكي قديش نسبه الخطا فيه بس بس
للمستقبل القريب او البعيد شو اكثر شيء
نحن يمكن ان نتوقعه على صعيد اختصاصك
تحديدا في امراض القلب
مثلا
الانترفيتيشن تبع صور الاشعه احيانا
الذكاء الاصطناعي في الوقت الحالي في قاعد
عم بشتغل عشان يعطيك صوره الاشعه يحكي لك
شو فيها اذا في عندك امراض او لا انا
بالنسبه لامراض القلب وكهربت امراض القلب
في عنا الاي اي الذكاء الاصطناعي نستعمل
احيانا بالمابتينغ اللي هو لحتى تشوف
الكهرباء الغلط وين عم تيجي ممكن وين عم
تيجي في القلب هلا اذا كان الاصطناعي كثير
مهم لدرجه نيو اندسن اللي هي افخم
مجله طبيه في العالم او من الافخم انه
السنه الجاي بال2024 اعلنوا انهم راح
يعملوا منها كامله للذكاء الاصطناعي
جامعات كتير كبيره زي ما تفضلت بمايو
كلينك بجامعه نيويورك في عندهم قسم كامل
للذكاء الاصطناعي في القلب فهذا الموضوع
لساته عم بتطور كتير ولسه
الخوارزميات قاعده عم تنبني بس شو مشكلات
هذا باعتقادها او مشكله الذكاء الاصطناعي
بالمطلق يعني شو اللي ما وصل له بعد حتى
يكون عنده نسبه خطا حتى الان لماذا لم
يستطع بعد ان يعوض الطبيب
هلا الذكاء الاصطناعي بيعتمد الخوارزميه
اللي بيعتمد على الشخص اللي يفيدت اللي
بتحط المعلومات اللي فيها والشخص اللي
بيبنيها بالاخر الشخص اللي بيبني هذا
الذكاء الاصطناعي هو
انسان وفي اكثر من نوع من الخوارزميات
بالذكاء الاصطناعي فراح يضل في عنا زي
نسبه خطا بس السؤال اللي دائما المخوف
العالم كلياته هل هذا في الاخر راح ينوب
عن الطبيب لو بعد سنه سنتين او كم من سنه
البرسيجين الدقه صارت كتير عاليه لدرجه هل
هذا رح نوب عن الطبيب يعني هل راح يبطل في
اطباء اشعه ويصير كلياته يقرا عن طريق
الذكاء الاصطناعي ما بنعرف بس على الاغلب
لا لانه بيجي عندك اكثر من
شغله يعني في عندك اكثر من جانب جوانب
قانونيه جوانب امور مثل هيك بيكون له دور
كبير ولكن دون ان يعوض الاطباء او الطاقم
الطبي والعلاج عموما في المستشفيات
هذا ما نستطيع تصوره حتى الان لا نعرف
للمستقبل المتوسط والبعيد ولكن فيما يتعلق
يعني اهميه ما توصل اليه الذكاء الاصطناعي
في هذا المجال الى اي مدى انت تؤمن بانه
سيسهم اسهاما حقيقيا وجادا في
التشخيص الطبي المشترك اللي في اكثر من
عامل يعني مثلا اذا حكينا عن القلب ممكن
يكون في الات معينه يساهم فيها الذكاء
الاصطناعي مع
هنالك ولكن اذا كان في اشتراكات مضاعفات
اكثر من عضو يعني في في مشاكل هل ذكاء
الاصطناعي وصل الى مرحله قادر على يعني حل
هذا الموضوع او اكتشافه
هلا في الوقت الحالي لا بس هو هذا الشغله
يعني من ناحيه القديه عم يكبر الموضوع
يعني مثلا احنا بنحط فيس ميكرز بنحط اللي
هو البطاريات اللي بتساعد القلب واحده من
الامور اللي هو كل فتره وفتره انت لازم
تفحص المريض وتشوف اذا عنده شغال ممكن
تغير له
الشيرتن ثين موجوده بالبيس ميكر فهل
مستقبل تنظيم ضربات القلب ذكاء اصطناعي
بالضبط لتنظيم ضربات القلب هلا راح يكون
في اصطناعي في الفيس ميكرز انه هو لحاله
يشوف شو اللي عم بيصير مع المريض ويغير
اللي موجوده حتى يساعد المريض هاي وحده من
الامور هل رح يتغير بطريقه
عمليات الكي هل راح تصير نقدر يصير في دقه
اكثر نعرف وين كهرباء القلب راح تطلع
بهذول الامراض بهذول المرضى فيعني
المستقبل بالنسبه للاط بالنسبه للمرضى
طبعا هذا اشي كثير كويس لانه انت بتزيد
بتزيد الدقه
وبتزيد
راح تزيد احسن وتكون احسن بالنسبه للمرضى
بالنسبه للاطباء يمكن يكون في
يمكن الله اعلم بس يمكن يكون في مش
استبدال بس يعني سبورت معين للاطباء احنا
ما بنعرف صراحه كيف المستقبل اخدنا شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور محمد حجيري الاستشاري في
الامراض وكهربائيات القلب من عمان تحياتي
لك
بحيره الكنديه ربما تصبح دليلا على ان
البشر بداوا فصلا جديدا في الزمن
الجيولوجي وفق تقرير لواشنطن بوست قالت
مجموعه من العلماء يوم امس ان افضل دليل
على تاثير للبشريه على كوكبنا يمكن العثور
عليه في هذه البحيره الواقعه في مقاطعه
تحت رواسب البحيره ذات طبقات الدقيقه على
سجل 1000 عام من التاريخ البيئي من صنع
الانسان لتترك بصمه لا تمحى في السجل
الجيولوجي للارض ويمثل الاعلان العلمي هذا
خطوه حاسمه في جهد استمر لسنوات لتحديد ما
اذا كان الناس قد غيروا الكوكب بما يكفي
لاطلاق حقبه جديده في الزمن الجيولوجي منذ
عام 2009 جمعت هيئه علميه ادله على ان
كيمياء الارض ومناخها يختلفان بشكل جوهري
عن الظروف التي كانت سائده في خلال الاف
السنين الماضيه الهدف هناك تحديد البقعه
الجيولوجيه التي حافظت تماما على اثار
التحولات الخطيره التي احدثها وكانت هذه
البقعه في البحيره الكنديه اشار العلماء
الى ان التفاعلات البشريه مع البيئه قد
تكون لها تداعيات اقتصاديه وسياسيه محتمله
خاصه وان البشر بمختلف الدول مسؤولون بشكل
متساوي عن تحول الكوكب والانبعاثات
الكربونيه والاضرار البيئيه الاخرى اضافت
المجموعه ان الادله من بحيره كروفيلد
ومواقع اخرى لا يمكن انكارها وتظهر بشكل
اوضح او تظهر هناك بشكل اوضح كل عام
مشيرين الى انه طالما استمر الناس في
احداث فوضى بيئيه فان عواقب هذه الخيارات
ستستمر في الظهور في الارض
تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 المعلومات عن
سعيد للاستيلاء على ادوات ومعدات نوويه
على الاغلب مضلله التصريح هو للمتحدث باسم
الكريم
الاوكرانيه والذي اشار الى ان فاجنر وصلت
لقاعده فارونج 45 باغراض الاستيلاء على
المواد التي تعود للحكمه السوفياتيه كان
اغلب ما يتعلق بحقيقه تمر العسكري غامضا
والاكيد انه سيزداد غمضا بعدما كشف عن
اللقاء بين بوتين وقيادات فاغنر عقب
تمردها بخمسه ايام
الاسبانيه تجدد الموعد مع مهرجان الثيران
المثير المئات يعدون مع الثيران المتحفزه
والعدائيه في مسار يمتد لنحو الكيلومتر
بدءا من نقطه الانطلاق حتى الوصول الى
حلقه مصارعه الثيران محطه النهايه لم يخلف
الحادث سوى ثلاثه مصابين باصابات بسيطه
استمتع المشاركون والسائحون وبقيه الثيران
هي الوحيده التي لم تفهم لماذا كل هذا
[موسيقى]
صوره اليوم من الشرقيه المصريه مواطن حول
منزله الى مكتبه مجانيه للاطفال للقراءه
وتلقي العلم فصار منزله الاكثر ازدحاما في
قريته من الغرف الى الدرج لم تخلوا بقعه
الا وفيها طفل وكتاب وثالثهما الامل
والى هذه الصور التي ترد من بركان ايسلندا
الذي عاد ليقذف حممه البركانيه اذا كان
البركان قد بدا بالثوران بعد 11 شهرا من
انتهاء اخر ثوران له رسميا وهو في واد غير
ماهول ولكن على بعد حوالى 30 كيلومترا فقط
جنوب غرب العاصمه الايسلنديه
وهذه المنطقه المعروفه باسم بركان
فارق مرتين في العامين الماضيين دون
التسبب في اضرار او اضطرابات في الرحلات
الجويه على الرغم من قربها من مطار
ريكييفيكا مركز الحركه الجويه الدولي في
ايسلندا
والمطار اسمه
هذا المطار مفتوحا في البدايه وحفت سلطات
منذ البدايه السكان على عدم القيام برحله
الى البقاع نكتفي بهذا القدر ولكن اخبار
سعله تنقطع صيام بنزاموس تتابع في اخبار
الساعه الان سهام مساء الخير ماذا لديك
طبعا
نواصل ملف الناتو مدى تماسك الدول الاعضاء
في الحلف اضافه الى الازمه السودانيه عشيه
قمه القاهره المرتقبه شكرا تفضلي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات